madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
en autriche les premières équipes de
secours viennent de rejoindre le
funiculaire incendié commence d'examiner
les corps des victimes
alors que les enquêtes montrent les
insuffisances de la sécurité il y a un
an le grand sud de la france étaient
touchées par de terribles inondations
depuis à cuxac d'aude
les travaux de prévention n'ont toujours
pas démarré tout a été reconstruit à
l'identique ou presque aux états unis
rebondissements série à palm beach le
comptage manuel dame % des suffrages
fait état de quelques voix favorables à
al gore du coup la commission électorale
décide un nouveau dépouillement manuel
cinéma le film garde à vue de claude
miller revisité par les américains
suspicion avec jean hackman morgan
freeman et monica bellucci à huis clos
qui se déroule à porto rico en autriche
trente six heures après la tragédie
l'évidence s'est imposée les familles
savent désormais mais aucun corps ne
pourraient être acheminés dans la vallée
avant demain en toute fin de journée les
équipes de secours ont tout de même pu
pénétrer dans la première voiture
calcinée la chaleur du tunnel ayant
empêché jusqu'à présent l'accès des
secours reste la souffrance qui déchire
le visage de ses proches qui ont été
regroupés dans l'auberge de jeunesse de
kaprun soutenue par de nombreuses
équipes de psychologues
patrice rome d'elle
les deux jours de deuil décidées par le
gouverneur de la province de salzbourg
s'achève dans quelques heures mais le
chagrin et la compassion eux ignorent
horaires et décret et semblent
s'installer durablement à kaprun par
grappes
les proches des victimes arrivent dans
la station de ski immédiatement prise en
charge par l'armée autrichienne et les
bénévoles de la croix rouge
ils sont conduits à l'auberge de
jeunesse cet endroit est une sorte de
sas psychologique ici s'opère la
transition entre la peur et la vérité
entre les craintes et leur confirmation
un travail confié à des spécialistes
bien sûr à l'intérieur il y a beaucoup
de psychologues les familles ne savent
pas avec précision ce qui s'est passé
alors elles veulent savoir et nous on
tente de leur expliquer surtout on prend
soin d'elle
dans cette affaire ce qui est terrible
et qui nous rend amer c'est qu'on aurait
pu aider on avait assez de médecins
assez d'infirmières à ces délits comme
est en fait tout cela n'a servi à rien
dit il cela fait 40 ans qu'il sert la
croix rouge
invariablement les familles demandent
qu'on les conduise dans cette direction
au pied du glacier au plus près du lieu
de la catastrophe les autorités
acceptent volontiers elles savent que ce
genre de pèlerinage peut aider à
supporter la douleur en début de soirée
confirmant la rumeur qui enflait depuis
quelques heures
le chancelier autrichien débarquer
takapuna
bien sûr il s'associe à la peine des
familles avant d'affronter la presse
question faut-il la suivant l'exemple de
la france qui a cloué au sol ses
concorde fermer tous les funiculaires de
l'autriche
réponse du chancelier avant de prendre
une décision de ce genre il faut avoir
une vision claire de la situation
concernant l' enquête petit à petit le
macabre puzzle se mettent en place et
l'on commence à savoir comment les
skieurs ont été prises au piège et de
quelle façon les quelques rescapés ont
pu s'échapper du brasier
on sait également les insuffisances des
systèmes de sécurité contre les risques
d'incendié
le point avec pascal du scibo pros n'ont
fait qu'à cheminée du matériel et des
techniciens aujourd'hui pour l'instant
l'extrémité supérieure du tunnel
continue à cracher de la fumée
impossible de descendre
l'idée des autorités est simple attendre
la dissipation des fumées en installant
des normes treuil au sommet puis câble
et ce qui reste des cabines et les tirer
vers le haut c'est la méthode la moins
dangereuse
les personnes nées sur qu'elle
fonctionnera la cabine est dans un tel
état que nous ne sommes pas sûrs de la
sécuriser elle peut se disloquer alors
les responsables se contentent de donner
des précisions sur les circonstances du
drame
il n'y avait pas d'extincteurs dans la
partie passagers des voitures
et quand les plus chanceux ont réussi à
en sortir il n'avait que quelques
centimètres pour se glisser entre la
cabine et la paroisse dans une obscurité
totale
les rescapés l'ont racontée à l'équipe
médicale ils se sont rassemblés à
l'extérieur sur l'escalier de faire mon
patient a crié ne partez pas vers le
haut il va y avoir un effet de cheminée
mais seuls huit autres passagers l'ont
entendu les autres sont montés et ont
péri en l'absence de galerie piétonne
séparer du tunnel
celui ci est donc devenu un piège dans
lequel les services de secours n'aurait
rien pu faire
même s'il était arrivé plus vite mais en
direct de kaprun patrice romedenne
comment les opérations de récupération
et de la cabine et des corps des
victimes vont elles se dérouler selon
quel calendrier
apparemment rien avant demain matin ou
plutôt oui vraiment ou plutôt béatrice
c'est une opération qui va être longue
qui va être pénible et qui va prendre au
moins plusieurs jours parce que vous
savez les gens qui descendent dans le
tunnel en ce moment il faut pouvoir
assurer leur sécurité ces gens sont
confrontés à de nombreux problèmes
d'abord parce qu'elle tous ces bons le
disais tout à l'heure la fumée à
l'intérieur on ne peut pas rester
longtemps
ensuite il ya une différence entre des
cendres rentrer dans un wagon voir ce
qui s'y passe et puis descendre est
resté travailler de longues minutes de
longueur ça pour l'instant les
sauveteurs ou en tout cas les personnes
qui descendent dans le tunnel ne peuvent
pas le faire
autre problème auquel ces gens là sont
confrontés c'est là l'essence même du
tunnel je dirais il ya une ouverture en
haut une ouverture en bas ils ne peuvent
pas travailler en passant par le bas
parce que ils ont peur qu'il ya des
débris qui leur tombe sur la figure donc
ils sont obligés de passer par en haut
on vous imaginez le nombre de rotations
qu'il peut y avoir tout au long de la
journée pour amener les personnes qui
descendent ensuite dans le tunnel voilà
c'est quand tous ces problèmes sont
réglés qu'on peut penser à remonter les
corps ou
ce qu'il en reste car il ne faut pas se
cacher on sait qu'il ya des personnes
qui ont été asphyxiées mais d'autres
l'ont brûlée vive
il va falloir faire un gros travail pour
les identifier en fera sans doute appel
à la génétique je conclurai en
visionnant une information concernant
les 18 personnes qui ont été blessées et
hospitalisées
15 d'entre elles ont pu regagner leur
domicile et quitter la région
aujourd'hui et trois d'entre elles
restent encore à l'hôpital mais leurs
jours ne sont pas en danger
merci patrick van den comme l'autriche
la france possède elle aussi son métro
des alpes à tignes le funiculaire est de
conception identique mais il a été
construit tout récemment et selon la
direction de la station
il bénéficie de tous les systèmes de
sécurité voyons quels sont les
dispositifs anti-incendie mise en place
de quoi sécuriser les skieurs qui malgré
tout aujourd'hui avec du vague à l'âme
didier guyot chanteuse martin
compétition de snowboard ce matin sur le
glacier de tignes pour atteindre le
sommet il faut emprunter le funiculaire
un métro des neiges mise en service en
avril 93 capacité des deux voitures 330
personnes longueur du tunnel 3 km 5
les matériaux de la ram sont
ininflammable des extincteurs et dh sont
stockés dans des niches et on compte 4
sus de secours
tout semble avoir été prévu mais le
drame autrichien est un électrochoc pour
les responsables on pourra bien sûr se
repencher sur ce problème
hier soir on a fait des émules
applications jeux
l'installation
un plan de sauvetage
j ai testé chaque année
on a des plans d la question des plans
aussi de
je sais que mes étés incendies dans les
gares de départ par exemple maintenant
je crois qu'il faut aller plus loin et
vraiment savoir
est ce que c'est une dynamo est ce que
cette patrie
quel a été le problème gabon en autriche
les deux extrémités du tunnel était
ouverte provoquant un appel d'air
meurtrier
ici en cas d'incendié des rideaux sont
immédiatement baissé gare de départ et
gare d'arrivée sont ainsi fermé
actuellement au tourne à 100% du
potentiel mais trois moteurs grande
vitesse 12 mètres à la seconde le trajet
sedan 6 minutes sur les 932 m de
dénivelé tous les faits et gestes de la
ram sont vérifiées et une fois par
semaine un exercice de sécurité est
organisée on met la ram à 700 m 1000 m
1200 m on nous coupe le réseau principal
de courant et on reste un nouveau toutes
les combinaisons et toutes ces
combinaisons bien sûr sont répertoriés
et chaque semaine on refait un moyen
différent en fait d'évacuation 1
millions de passagers par an ce nous
transporter par le funiculaire et ce
matin beaucoup essayé de ne pas trop
penser à l'autriche j'avais us
commencent à échanger c'est pas la peine
j'ai montré pas non en fait il est
fiable que je vais essayer at-il jamais
eu d'accident avec attend du bois depuis
93 cet incident ont été répertoriés des
incidents sans gravité
aux etats unis le compte n'est toujours
pas bon imaginez qu'en floride à palm
beach après un nouveau dépouillement
manuel d'un pour cent des bulletins
les erreurs sont manifestes avec une
différence de 19 voix pour al gore de
quoi susciter la décision de la
commission électorale d'un recomptage
manuel de tous les votes du comté
la guerre des nerfs n'est pas prête de
s'achever jérôme n'est ce n'est pas la
bataille de gore contre bush c'est la
bataille du peuple américain ne me
touchez pas où je vous fais arrêter la
tension monte aux états unis entre
manifestants pro gore et pro bush le
monde entier a les yeux tournés vers le
petit comté de palm beach en floride
le choix du président de la première
puissance mondiale se joue à quelques
millimètres près à l'emplacement d'une
perforation visiblement difficile à
discerner quand le bulletin de vote
devient une énigme c'est tout le système
électoral qui est remise en cause
le nouveau comptage manuel de 1% des
votes donne 33 voix en plus à al gore
contre 14 seulement à george bush
d'où un nouveau coup de théâtre ensemble
des circonstances aussi je demande que
le conseil engage un nouveau comptage
manuel de tous les votes pour l'élection
présidentielle de mire le parti
républicain vient d'engager une
procédure contre ce comptage manuel qui
considèrent comme aléatoire si les
partisans de gore continue à demander
que les votes soient comptés et
recomptés
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit satisfait des
résultats ici en floride
nous pourrions être forcé de suggérer
qu'il y ait de nouveau décompte dans
tous les états que nous avons perdu de
justesse
comme pour ajouter à la confusion la
police a découvert deux urnes scellées
dans un hôtel et dans une église
le contenu de ces urnes n'a pas été
révélé le suspense continue le candidat
républicain semble moins sûr de lui
alors que son adversaire démocrate ou
sortir du service dominical se montre
confiant et souriant
les de washington etienne leenhardt
entre le burlesque suspense et le
ridicule les humoristes doivent s'en
donner à coeur joie
mais à quel moment les américains
vont-ils ressentir les risques d'une
crise institutionnelle
oui c'est vrai qu'au pays de bill gates
de l'internet on a tendance à se dire
qu'il est hallucinant que dans certains
états on vote encore avec des urnes qui
datait des systèmes qui datent du siècle
dernier ceci dit je ne crois pas que
pour l'instant on puisse parler de crise
institutionnelle la question qui se pose
c'est à la longue liste ou longues
quand est ce que l'opinion publique
américaine dira stock nous voulons
savoir quel est le nom de notre nouveau
président est la date qui revient dans
toutes les conversations c'est celle de
vendredi prochain le 17 novembre la date
butoir pour que l'on connaisse les
résultats officiels de cet état de
floride
si les choses devaient aller au delà
s'il y avait des recours devant les
tribunaux il est probable que l'on
rentrerait alors de votre dans une
nouvelle phase une phase de véritable
crise des institutions américaines ni al
gore ni george bush n'ayant intérêt le
vainqueur parce qu'il entamera quoi
qu'il arrive considérablement affaibli
cette nouvelle présidence et le vaincu
parce qu'en donnant l'impression qu'il
s'accroche et bien il hypothéquerait ses
chances de pouvoir se représenter dans
quatre ans un dernier mot pour dire que
la journée de demain va être extrêmement
importante c'est demain en effet qu'un
juge en floride va dire si ce comptage
manuel qui a commencé ce matin est légal
ou non
vous savez que les républicains tentent
de s'y opposer mais si le juge considère
que c'est une opération légale et bien
l'espoir va changer d'écran parce qu'on
le disait ce comptage manuel semble être
beaucoup plus favorable au démocrate al
gore
merci etienne leenhardt il ya un an jour
pour jour de terribles inondations
touchent et le grand sud de la france
une catastrophe coûtant la vie à 34
personnes
aujourd'hui à cuxac d'aude dans le
département le plus touché plusieurs
centaines de personnes accompagnées par
des élus locaux se sont retrouvés pour
cette commémoration à lâcher de colombes
symboles de vie et de reconstruction
restent l'émotion et de la colère des
villageois
une partie de la population à boycotter
la cérémonie
le traumatisme est toujours là mais
surtout les habitants ne se sentent pas
plus protégés que l'an passé les travaux
de prévention n'ont toujours pas démarré
on a reconstruit à l'identique
rien donc pour empêcher un nouveau
désastre léo lamberton syrie papier elle
a acheté ce terrain
un mois avant les inondations deux cent
mille francs pour y bâtir une petite
maison
mais lorsque l'on s'y perez a demandé un
permis de construire il a été refusé car
à cuxac les parcelles à risque sont
désormais inconstructibles c'est
d'ailleurs le seul vrai changement
un an après la catastrophe démoralisé
complet on voulait faire tout ça
maintenant on est endetté il se retrouve
avec un terrain qu'on ne sait jamais si
on va construire dessus cinq morts 80%
du village sinistré
cuxac d'aude fut la commune la plus
durement touchés par les terribles
inondations des 12 et 13 novembre 99 les
habitants accusent le pont de chemin de
fer d'avoir aggravé la catastrophe ce
pont d'une seule arche aurait empêché
l'eau de s'écouler naturellement et en
cédant aurait provoqué une vague
meurtrière
un an après le pont a été reconstruit à
l'identique et le maire de cuxac ne
décolère pas je comprends qu'on n'est
plus le reconstruire à lui un clip tout
de suite parce qu'il y avait quand même
des problèmes économiques avant ça je ne
comprends très bien
est ce que je veux c'est que les plus
vite possible se trouve
soient doublées ou triplées fonctionner
au nez plus est le wagon leurs prix même
constat pour les digues refaite comme
avant elles n'ont été ni rallonger ni
rehausser le maire de cuxac rang
voudrait deux supplémentaires pour mieux
protéger le village mais elles ne sont
pas à l'ordre du jour
en fait le vaste plan d'aménagement des
basses plaines de l'aude de promis il ya
un an et n'est toujours qu'un projet les
travaux ne commenceront pas avant
plusieurs mois
car les études viennent à peine d'être
lancé le temps de trouver le maître
d'ouvragé est de définir le contenu de
l'étude
nous y sommes alors effectivement ça
peut paraître très long à l'observateur
extérieur mais je pense que il n'ya pas
une perte de temps
anormal je suis inquiet parce que c'est
vrai que si une grosse inondation aviv
des poules estaing et nous serons comme
l'an dernier mme son affaire comme un
peu mieux informé que l'an dernier mais
nous aurons les pédalos comme la
gagnante moi et ça c'est insupportable
à cuxac l'exaspération domine non
seulement les travaux de prévention
n'ont pas été faits mais même les
travaux de réfection laisse à désirer
ainsi la toute nouvelle route qui
traverse le lotissement est
potentiellement dangereuse chaque enfant
qu'il voudra lui met une couche sur
l'accrochage ça fait quatre ans ils vont
nous faire le digg
ça fait qu l'eau de s'évacuer sur le
chemin qui ce qui devrait faire entre
deux rames tram mieux dans les maisons
plus je sais même pas s'il ya une
définition de ce que l'on peut ressentir
à queue dans la peur actuellement c'est
vrai qu'on est dans la peur alors de
quoi alors la peur la peur de la pluie
la peur d'une autre inondation la peur
de ne pas être encore dans un village
sécurisé c'est vraiment difficile à
vivre
convaincus qu'ils ne peuvent compter que
sur eux mêmes les sinistrés se sont
regroupés en association
certains ont même porté plainte contre x
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
et tous redoutent les prochaines fortes
pluies car ils sont persuadés d'être une
nouvelle fois inondées c'est demain que
s'ouvrira la conférence de l'est sur
l'environnement pendant dix jours 184
pays vont tenter de trouver concrètement
un projet commun pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique provoqué par
les rejets de gaz dans l'atmosphère les
marges de manoeuvre sont étroites
l'europe et les états unis ont des
points de vue divergent quant aux
méthodes pour réduire l'effet de serre à
nice menteur
depuis dix ans la communauté
internationale tergiverse les sommets se
succèdent mais les décisions sont
difficiles à prendre
le sommet de kyoto en 1997 marque tout
de même un tournant les pays
participants se mettent enfin d'accord
sur des objectifs de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre en 2010 la planète devra
diminué de 5,2 pour cent ses émissions
par rapport à 1990 l'union européenne
accepte une réduction de 8%
les etats unis 2 7% et le japon 2 6%
voilà pour la théorie la pratique la
mise en application de ces engagements
sera défini à l'ail entre les deux
conférences les scientifiques sont
devenus beaucoup plus alarmiste
ces attitudes sont devenue suffisamment
faible pour peu aucun retard dans les
prises de mesures efficaces de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre ne puisse être
humainement justifié
l'europe souhaite que chaque pays
s'engage à diminuer sa propre
consommation de pétrole ou de gaz
mais les principaux pollueurs etats unis
en tête espèrent biaisé acheté par un
système de troc des permis d'émissions
aux pays les moins polluants comme
l'australie ou gagner des points on est
dans les pays en voie de développement
installer une industrie prend autre
solution pour les états unis planter des
forêts des arbres qui absorberait le co2
pendant leur croissance et permettra en
échange de continuer tranquillement à
polluer semaine décisive concernant la
crise de la vache folle avec
vraisemblablement la suspension des
farines animales dans l'alimentation des
volailles des ports et du poisson mesure
que s'apprête à prendre le gouvernement
demain les états généraux de
l'alimentation s'ouvriront à lyon un
véritable forum au cours duquel sera
débattue le bien fondé de ce moratoire
réclamé temps par dominique voynet hier
que par josé bové ou encore par
l'opposition sur le terrain certains
éleveurs ont déjà fait le pari de
l'agriculture biologique comme le monde
ce reportage de david bauer et de
jean-françois chevet qui se sont rendus
au salon marjolaine à paris
du poulet bio élevé au grain et en plein
air pour cet éleveur pas question de
nourrir les volailles avec des farines
animales
le régime alimentaire et strictes
uniquement des céréales biologiques et
pourtant cette année les questions du
public sont plus nombreux public
la vache folle sur une rue une demande
très importante débordante
voilà on a question si mon genou pour
les violons style dumange prix de la
farine de viande assez clair que non non
jamais mangé mais c'est une question qui
revient à nouveau le poisson d'élevage
un autre produit généralement nourri aux
farines animales
mais là aussi le consommateur doit être
rassurée et la filière bio lui propose
une alternative
ils veulent un produit élevé
naturellement la garantie qu'on peut
leur apporter
j'ai pour qu'ils demandent aux
interrogations du public
hésitations du côté des politiques
faut-il interdire purement et simplement
l'utilisation des farines animales avant
de prendre une décision définitive au
gouvernement certains ministres
demandent une suspension provisoire
nous avons besoin de plusieurs mois pour
avoir l'avis des experts de l'afssa
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé qu'un
moratoire soit décidée par le premier
ministre sur l'utilisation de farines
animales en agriculture pour
l'alimentation des animaux
une décision délicate car lourde de
conséquence l'interdiction totale
coûterait 5 milliards de francs par an
entre le coup de destructions et celui
du remplacement des farines le
gouvernement attend l'avis des
scientifiques
l'opposition elle s'impatiente moi je
pense que le gouvernement patauge il y a
une semaine il nous disait qu'il ne
fallait pas les arrêter on attendait les
scientifiques
aujourd'hui ils nous disent qu'ils vont
les arrêter je crois qu'il faut aller
très vite
des questions auxquelles les producteurs
bio répondent déjà et les consommateurs
sont de plus en plus nombreux à les
rejoindre dans leur démarche et demain
soir l'émission mots croisés d'arlette
chabot et d'alain duhamel aura pour
thème la vache folle psychose ou vrai
danger les réponses aux questions que
vous vous posez sur le plateau parmi des
médecins il verrait vétérinaire jean
glavany et josé bové au congrès des
verts à toulouse on est finalement
arrivé à
laborieuse accord qui donne une unité de
façade mouvement divisée entre si
courant et plusieurs fortes
personnalités
dominique voynet et noël mamère sauve
les apparences albert mycosis il verrait
sans une vraie pièce de théâtre avec ses
portes qui claquent et la grande
réconciliation finale après 36 heures de
votre ville les verts ont réussi à
s'accorder sur une synthèse
elle rassemble les amis de dominique
voynet ceux de noël mamère et les écolos
historique dans cet accouchement au
forceps plusieurs victimes jean-luc
bennahmias le secrétaire national du
mouvement a préféré quitter toulouse
avant la fin lassé par les atermoiements
marie christine blandin et ses amis dont
le projet alternatif n'a pas séduit et
plus généralement les verts abonnés au
psychodrame à chaque congrès on est dans
un mouvement vivent un mouvement qui n'a
pas su encore adapter ses règles de
fonctionnement à sa croissance ce qui
fonctionnait bien quand on était
quelques centaines de militants qui se
connaissaient par coeur ne fonctionne
plus quand on est plusieurs milliers
donc il va falloir qu'on y réfléchisse
je suis satisfait parce que je pense que
nous avons posé les bases d'une majorité
stable et que maintenant nous sommes en
mesure ça nous le démontrer de revenir
en force dans la société et de changer
notre rapport au parti socialiste
préalable à tout accord avec les
socialistes l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle aux législatives
le texte indique aussi la volonté de
rénover les structures internes et fixe
le principe d'une primaire pour désigner
un candidat aux présidentielles primaire
prévue au printemps prochain
c'est donc mardi prochain que se
déroulera à paris une cérémonie aux
invalides à la mémoire de jacques chaban
delmas
peu après l'ancien premier ministre sera
inhumé dans les pyrénées atlantiques ask
dans cette petite commune qui depuis 30
ans lui servait de refuge
réaction de ses proches et de ses amis
reportage éric perrin bernard bonne arme
du pays basque il aimait par dessus tout
l'authenticité de l'arrière-pays
après l'hommage officiel aux invalides
mardi prochain c'est dans l'intimité de
cette église que les proches de jacques
chaban delmas se rassembleront son corps
sera ensuite inhumé dans ce cimetière
comme il l'avait lui-même souhaité ça
voulait dire que pour lui à ce qu'un
était son village et l'allemand il était
à tout le monde et l'état de para tôt
mais dans son esprit était
essentiellement d'ascain car depuis plus
de trente ans jacques chaban delmas
avait fait de cette bergerie perdu dans
la montagne son lieu d'intimité
seuls les proches les amis véritables y
étaient reçus le docteur l'adec faisait
partie de ceux là ils s'étaient
rencontrés après guerre sur un terrain
de rugby et quand ils se retrouvaient ce
n'était jamais pour parler politique
n'ont parlé que de sport de filles trucs
comme ça
c'est un gars fidèles quoi c'est un mec
qui était fidèle dans ses amitiés ça
c'est sûr et non non c'est qu'il
frappait le plus c'était soit
l'intelligence je crois c'est ça qui est
un séducteur et quand même c'était c'est
vrai séducteur il aimait bien séduire
même ses amis quoi et des amis dans ce
pays basque il en avait comme jean gare
à idées ancien joueur de golf
professionnel avec kiel participer à des
compétitions un chat ben toujours aussi
sportif que chaleureux très ouvert et
très détendu et très agréable mais
toujours avec dans le golfe et l'esprit
sportif et voulant bien jouer faire la
performance et accrocheur accrocheur
comme il l'a fait dans le vide
c'est au pied des pyrénées que jacques
chaban-delmas reposera tout jamais s'ils
n'étaient pas basque de naissance pour
ses amis d'ici c'était bien un basque
d'adoption
on y serait la fin d'un détournement
d'avion un avion russe aucun rapport
avec la défense de la cause
palestinienne les 48 passagers sont
sains et saufs le pirates armés d'une
fausse bombe serait un déséquilibré
originaire du daguestan ehud barak qui
avait rebroussé chemin alors qu'il
faisait route vers washington devrait
arriver aux états unis où il rencontrera
bill clinton à tel aviv la veuve
d'itzhak rabin ardent défenseur de la
paix et ancien premier ministre
assassiné il ya cinq ans léa rabin est
décédé aujourd'hui à l'âge de 72 ans
elle était la dépositaire de l'héritage
de son mari et avait repris le flambeau
au travaillant sans relâche pour que ne
soit pas remis en cause le processus de
paix jacques chirac a exprimé ce soir
son immense tristesse saluant une femme
de courage de conviction tout camionnage
haussmann qui évoque son engagement en
faveur de la paix alain le roy c'était
il ya cinq ans presque jour pour jour
les arabes in enterrer son mari premier
ministre d'israël tué par un extrémiste
juif
le monde entier avait été frappé par la
douleur et la dignité de ses preuves
entouré de ses deux enfants et
découvrait aussi une femme qu'elle est
reprendre comme un héritage le flambeau
de la paix transmis par son mari
j'appartiens disent elles à tous ceux
qui croient au processus de paix le
chemin tracé par ids ac illzach
elle l'avait connu à l'âge de 15 ans
tous deux étaient dans le palmarés le
corps d'élite de la haganah l'armée
secrète juive d'avant la création de
l'état d'israël sa famille avait émigré
d'allemagne en 1933 aux premières heures
du nazisme
léa et idziak ne se sont plus quittés
depuis cette époque héroïque dans les
bons et mauvais moments
jusqu'à ce 4 novembre 1995 elle était
encore au côté de son mari
quelques instants avant qu'il ne soit
assassiné
depuis elle n'a cessé de parcourir le
monde en intransigeante gardienne du
processus de paix voulue par son mari
allant jusqu'à critiquer ehud barak
une déception totale 10 et elle est
aujourd'hui sa disparition suscite des
réactions mitigées et la mort de sa
femme tu as
c'est comme une deuxième flammes qui
s'éteint ce qu'ils ont fait n'a pas été
très constructives pour rispal au
confort a été plutôt destructif la
semaine dernière pour le 5e anniversaire
de la mort dit jack rabin
elle était déjà hospitalisé mais avait
tenu à transmettre par la voix de sa
fille un dernier message de paix pas si
évident par les temps qui courent en
corée du sud violentes manifestations
des salariés de la société d'abu près de
dix mille d'entre eux ont marché dans le
centre de séoul en question la perte de
nombreux emplois après la faillite de la
compagnie affrontements avec les forces
de l'ordre qui n'ont pas hésité à
réprimer très durement cette marche en
france dans le lot il y a un an sept
spéléologues bloqués dans la grotte des
vitarelles ont été secourus après dix
jours d'efforts et de moyens
considérables suscitant au passage une
certaine polémique cet anniversaire nous
offre l'occasion de voir aujourd'hui
comment s'organisent ces secours près de
besançon lance de serre fait jean
françois meunier ont suivi pendant 24
heures une centaine de spéléologues à
l'entraînement pour une fois ce n'est
pas pour le plaisir
une soixantaine de spéléo participent
aujourd'hui un exercice grandeur nature
l'objectif souvient de leurs camarades
qui a fait une chute dans un gouffre à
180 mètres de profondeur mais qui paie
pour la fin on faire un - faire un
diagnostic
ensuite en fonction de diagnostic on
demandera l'équipement nécessaire
civière et et
moyen de datel fadoq est votre matériel
spécialisé plusieurs heures de descente
parfois avant de trouver le blesser et
de lui assurer les premiers soins une
suspicion de fracture du fémur
les secours peuvent donc duré longtemps
d'où la nécessité de protéger la victime
jouffroy pcpc de poids show pesté de
poids chaud pour que la civière puisse
pas celle espérée aux artificiers vont
devoir quelquefois élargir certains
passages à la dynamique la chute n'est
pas la seule cause des accidents souvent
c'est la montée des eaux dans les
souterrains qui surprend les
spéléologues
il est tout à fait important de
sensibiliser les spéléologues à ce
phénomène pour qu'il sache quoi faire
s'ils sont piégés on va dire par une
crue souvenez-vous l'an dernier une crue
brutale avait coincé sept spéléologues
dans le gouffre des vitarelles dans le
lot il avait fallu dix jours pour les
retrouver
percer un puits d'accès et enfin les
ramener à la surface sains et saufs
la facture des secours a atteint trois
millions et demi de francs 300 fois plus
que pour un sauvetage ordinaire au 8-ter
elle il s'agissait dans ce cours
effectivement exceptionnel où pour la
première fois des forages été mis en
oeuvre
les coûts des forages effectivement sont
élevés mais c'était la première fois la
plupart du temps voir tout le temps nous
n'utilisons pas cette technique
les spéléologues veulent assurer leurs
propres secours
chacun d'entre eux pourrait se trouver
en position de victime et ils sont les
plus familiers de ce type de terrain
sur les grosses cours comme il ya eu
dernièrement on peut être appelé
effectivement donc nous l'intérêt quand
il ya des exercices comme ici c'est d'y
participer pour être au point
techniquement 24 heures après le début
de l'exercice
la fausse victime sort du faux piège
mission accomplie pour les secouristes
bénévoles prêts à intervenir aussi en
situation réelle c'est nice à lyon c'est
le français arnaud clément qui a
remporté le tournoi en s'imposant en
deux sets 7-6 7-6 face à l'espagne à
patrick rafter tête de série numéro 8
une nouvelle réussite pour le joueur
français qui remporte ainsi son premier
succès sur le circuit professionnel il
est actuellement 22e au classement
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de suspicion il s'agit du remake du film
de claude miller garde à vue où
s'affrontaient michel serrault et lino
ventura dans cette version revisitée
morgan freeman dinac man et la très
belle monica bellucci s'impose à huis
clos dont l'action se déroule à porto
rico
marie-jo joint force entre juan à porto
rico le corps d'une fillette violée et
assassinée a été découvert par un
puissant avocat de l'ide une découverte
qui fait de lui le suspect numéro 1 cité
du gant
le remake américain vu garde à vue de
claude miller change de décor mais
reprend avec fidélité le célèbre duel
lino ventura michel serrault qu'est-ce
qu'il peut morgan freeman dans le rôle
du policier consciencieux et exposé jean
hackman dans celui d'une table si fier
de sa très jeune épouse un rôle tenu en
1981 par romy schneider repris ici par
la troublante monica bellucci et j'étais
là
à l'écouter travailler avec des acteurs
comme morgan freeman john hoffman
c'était être à l'école du cinéma parce
que juste de les voir travailler c'est
magnifique c'est beau aussi les voir
comme maclean's ont fait tellement des
films de voir qu'on me sens encore accès
d'une hackman et qui prennent des notes
en train de travailler
c'était lors du tournage de superman que
jean athmane avait découvert le film de
claude miller un coup de foudre qui l'a
poussé 20 ans plus tard a entraîné
morgan freeman dans la production de
suspicion la mise en scène a été confiée
à stéphane hopkins réalisateur des
suites de freddy pour la modernité
vous comprenez la raison pour laquelle
vous êtes encore là serait peut-être
temps de contacter un avocat
je suis avocat l'en de coeur
l'affrontement entre deux hommes
intransigeant et enlever dieu mais aussi
dévoré par l'ambition commissariat
central de 103 alger le commissaire
baiser je suis dans mon bureau en
compagnie de l'inspecteur owens en train
d'interroger monsieur arst nous donner
la permission d'enregistrer cette
conversation vous avez devant vous
quelqu'un qui représente pour le pouvoir
et tout à coup vous avez le pouvoir sur
lui et web
croyez moi vous profiter intensément de
ce moment là il n'avait pas les droits
face aux 20 km cette manière à voir
surtout pour un trio d'acteurs
remarquables qui redonne toute sa force
à ce drame en huis clos le mois de la
photo avec cette évocation en couleur ou
en noir et blanc une balade des deux
côtés de la scène ponctuée par le talent
de photographe qui ont saisi
l'instantané chaque dufour jean lui me
la pari insensé paris admirer paris y
visiter mais surtout paris photographie
le photographe c'est un bateau c'est un
marcheur pour ça d'ailleurs mon avis que
les programmes si longtemps alors ce
soit à la fois des pêcheurs d'image des
flâneurs de regards qui quelque part par
la lenteur voix capte appréhender pêche
ce qu'on ne voit pas quand on se dépêche
ces poteaux magnifique du paris des
années 50 on les doit à ce monsieur
franck horvat j'étais peut être le
premier à utiliser l objectif de 400 mm
dans la rue et salle à l'époque ça fait
beaucoup de fait c'est un peu ça qui a
démarré ma carrière celle là beaucoup
plus récentes sont en couleur mais c'est
toujours paris vu par l'artiste
là c'est métro la semaine c'est celle là
c'est le sous-sol bricolage iberia la
pause c'est le jardin d'acclimatation et
ainsi cliché après clichés paris
recadrer ne cesse d'être ré inventé ça
donne vraiment envie de flâner
c'est une ballade l'irréel une balade
imaginaire une ballade mélancolique une
balade dans lequel il a fait de
l'esthétique de la photographie du
conceptuel à l'humaniste du passé au
présent et puis au fond cinéma que
chaque aspect hangars abandonnés usine
désaffectée cathédrale oublier pour les
photographes qui ont des idées paris
offre mille possibilités à new bell en a
profité j'ai pas voulu en voir plus
comme je dis que vous nommez en fait
j'ai aussi limité exactement à ce que je
vois de ma fenêtre et vous avez fait ça
pendant combien d'années alors je suis
arrivée là où 92 m et 100 m en 2000 je
continue
marie humbert mais aussi paris en guerre
celle de 14 des lunettes c'est pour les
vues stéréoscopiques au début du siècle
ça se faisait beau
l'exploit c'est bien c'est bien quand on
voit la vie à l'époque de la première
heure
et
si à travers toutes ces expositions à
l'hiver c'est évidemment sur paris on
pouvait réinventer paris et revoir à
paris différent que celui qu'on connaît
pas ce serait pari réussi j'ajouterai
avis aux amateurs que la plupart des 56
exposition consacrée à paris sont
gratuites autrement dit allez y allez
souriez vous êtes filmés
nous avons appris le décès la nuit
dernière de franck pourcel à l'âge de 87
ans chef d'orchestre et violoniste il
était célèbre dans le monde entier avait
été le premier à populariser la musique
classique avec son grand orchestre
notamment dans les années 60 70
franck pourcel l'avait débuté comme
violoniste à l'opéra de marseille il y
avait accompagné lucienne boyer il avait
également co écrit la musique de
chariots interprété par têtu la clark
nos pensées vont ce soir à sa famille ce
fan de ce journal je vous en rappelle le
principal titre en autriche les
premières équipes de secours viennent de
rejoindre le funiculaire incendié
commençe d'examiner les corps des
victimes
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinet 20h50 d'urgence 00h30 de
l'édition de la nuit leur expliquer
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités gérard
morin reçoit le chanteur khaled 13h le
journal gérard holtz 20h vous
retrouverez claude sérillon je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
soirée
non
je